Hello, and welcome to another edition of modeling the masters. My name is Evan Carmichael and today
We're going to be talking about the famous entrepreneur walt Disney and how you can model his strategies to achieve success with your business
Everyone knows walt Disney for his movies theme parks and cast of characters. What most people don't know is when he first started out?
He had no money he had to live in his office because he couldn't afford [write] for an apartment
And he survived on a diet of cold beans because he couldn't afford food
By committing to his business and sticking with it
He was now able to build a business [that] has almost 40 billion [dollars] in revenue
So [today], we're going to look at three lessons that you can learn for wealth is in success and apply it into your company
Lesson number one is find something that you love Walt Disney grew up in the early
1900's on a farm in Missouri and developed the passion for drawing
So much, so that one of his neighbors actually paid him to draw some cartoons of his horses when Walt Disney got to school
He found that he was a good student
But he really enjoyed doodling as opposed to paying attention to his teachers he connected with one of his high school papers and started drawing
patriotic cartoons for the school paper
When he was 16, though he found that school just wasn't for him
So he dropped out join the red cross
Learn to become an ambulance driver, and actually was shipped to France to become an ambulance driver over there
He couldn't lose that passion for drawing and cartooning
And he ended up plastering his ambulance full of different cartoon creations that he had made
People knew him on the street because he was the ambulance driver with all the different cartoons blasted on his ambulance
He decided that cartooning was for him
he was going to be an artist and [return] to America to start his career as an artist, so
Lesson number one really is make sure you have that strong passion for your business if you don't really love it
It's going to be hard to succeed as a business owner if you look at any famous entrepreneur
And why they serve the business it wasn't for the money money comes when you're really passionate about what you're doing
So think about what is it that you do in your spare time? What do you really enjoy [doing]?
What gets you going in the morning? What are your hobbies, and how can you turn those into a potential business opportunity?
Lesson number two is push the boundaries Walt Disney first made his mark in 1934 when he proposed making a feature-length
Animation which had never been done [before] it was called snow white
Took three [years] to make [he] [went] a hundred percent over budget people thought he was crazy
For doing it you ran out of money at the end and had to actually act out the last scenes of the movie for his
Bankers to get the money he needed to close and finish the movie it ended up being a huge success
[it] was the biggest hit of the year [he] won an academy award for it, and it was a financial gain for him
Walt Disney's next big project was Disneyland [a]
338 Year project out in California a theme park which had nothing to do with his movies people thought he was crazy again
Why would you do this what tie does it have to your movie business?
But he had a vision he [was] determined to make it happen and again
It was a big success for him then he went on to open up the Walt Disney world in, Florida
And the company was able to open up different theme parks around the world
So the message for entrepreneurs here is push the boundaries you need to do something different to get your company noticed as a small entrepreneur
[there's] so much competition. It's so difficult to get on people's radar screens and make them pay attention to you
So [you] have [to] do something that's going to get your notice
Something that will help you stand out from the crowd
So what is it that will be your equivalent of a snow white something that's never been done before [it's] really going to get you
Notice and get the attention paid [to] your business
Lesson number three is stay top of mind
Walt Disney did everything he could to make sure people kept remembering the Walt Disney name
He did a lot of advertising as an example. So we did TV campaigns direct mail campaigns print ads
He even did grocery store coupon cutout so when you're at the grocery store, you're thinking about Walt Disney
He was also a pioneer in merchandising, so whenever a new feature film came out. That was a Walt Disney production
You would also be able to buy all the merchandise that went along with it
Today while Disney is [known] not only for its movies
But its TV stations theme parks dolls toys games and a whole host of other merchandise
So the lesson for entrepreneurs is stay top of mind
You need to do whatever you can to make sure your customers are always
Thinking about you the easiest way [to] grow a business is to [sell] more to your existing customers the hardest way to grow a business
is to go and try to find new
So do whatever you can to make sure your customers are always thinking about you
You're the first person that comes to mind when you're thinking about your product or service
And it's the best way to be able to grow your business Walt Disney is an entrepreneurial legend
Who's built up one of the most recognized companies in the world but remember when he first got started he had no money?
Nobody believed in him he had to live out of his office because he couldn't afford an apartment
And he survived on a diet of cold beans because he couldn't afford other food by following his lessons though you too can achieve
entrepreneurial success so remember find something you love
Push the boundaries and stay top of mind
I hope you've enjoyed this episode of modeling the masters to learn more about Walt Disney and his entrepreneurial success
You can visit our website at Evan Carmichael Com and you can also check out our blog?
Which is listed below I also want to take this [opportunity] to thank Fanta media for the great work
They've done in producing this video, and I hope you'll join us for the [next] episode of modeling the Masters
you